♪ ♪ ♪
- Les itinérants endurcis
d'Helsinki se retrouvent ici
tous les matins pour
réserver leur lit du soir.
Ils ne sont plus très nombreux.
Les autorités ont pris
les grands moyens pour
les sortir de la rue en créant
le programme Un toit d'abord.
Miguel Rojas ne vit plus dans
la rue depuis plusieurs années.e
35 appartements pour sans-abri.
- Seule condition pour y être
admis : s'engager par écrit
à essayer d'aller mieux.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a près de 7000 personnes
comme Miguel en Finlande
qui bénéficient du programme
Un toit d'abord dans
des immeubles construits
p p p p p p p pour leur donner
une nouvelle chance.
- Peter Fredriksson était
jusqu'à tout récemment
le grand responsable du
programme qui a démarré
12 ans plus tard, le nombre
de sans-abri a diminué
ieieieieieieieiers.
Pour y arriver, l'État
finlandais débourse 30 millions
d'euros, soit 45 millionsde dol.
- Ce programme permet de
réaliser des économies annuelles
en services sociaux et en soinst
supérieur au coût du programme,
un investissement plus
que rentable.
Avec e e e e e e e e e et
des prestations d'aide sociale,
Miguel arrive à payer une partie
de son loyer; c'est une
condition qui est requise
par le programme. c c c c c c É.
- Les candidats sont recrutés
dans des centres de jour
comme celui-ci. Seul problème :
le programme est victime
de sa popularité.
- La Finlande, comme le Canada,
a fermé plusieurs hôpitaux
psychiatriques au cours
des dernières années. Résultat :
on observe une hausse marquée
de la population itinérante
qui souffre de troubles mentaux.
- Le principal promoteur
du programme reconnaît
que le système a ses limites
s'il n'est pas accompagné
des services adéquats.
- Dans son ancienne vie,
Miguel Rojas était chanteur
et musicien. Sa dépendance
à diverses substances l'a
entraîné dans une profonde
dépression. Mais aujourd'hui, il
se considère à peu près guéri.
- L'expérience finlandaise
démontre que c'est précisément
l'accès à un logement qui
amène des itinérants à chercher
de l'aide et à obtenir
les soins pour s'en sortir.
♪ ♪ ♪